bonjour et ste zehst heures observé
toutes ces petites cellules un briquet
qui s'affairent à communiquer pour
produire un embryon des images à couper
le souffle des chercheurs aux interfaces
entre l'informatique et la biologie ont
collaboré pour développer de nouveaux
outils et sain pour permettre de percer
les secrets de la communication des
cellules embryonnaires
entre cris et chuchotements à votre avis
comment on passe dans neuf et condé un
animal tout bien formés
car si vous saviez déjà comment on fait
les bébés aujourd'hui on va découvrir
comment il se forme et bien cette
prouesse
on la doit aux cellules embryonnaires
qui s'organise à toute vitesse pour
croître se divisent et se transformer en
cellules de peau de cerveau et ça
jusqu'à obtenir un être entier avec
chaque tissu au bon endroit
pas comme sur un tableau cubiste par
exemple et pour s'organiser les cellules
embryonnaires communiquent entre elles
on pourrait croire que c'est un
mystérieux et silencieux mais je peux
vous dire que là dedans c'est toute une
cacophonie me
pour s'organiser les cellules sans voix
parfois des signaux chimiques à longue
distance
un peu comme si elle se criaient des
informations pour croître se diviser
s'organiser dans ce joli ballet qu'est
le développement embryonnaire ça les
scientifiques le savent et l'observer
déjà depuis un certain moment jusqu'à ce
que l'arrivée de nouveaux outils
bouleverse nos connaissances à ce sujet
les chercheurs ont développé un logiciel
nommé aztèque pour digitaliser des
images de cellules et modéliser leurs
formes et leurs contacts mais pour les
visualiser et les partager un nouvel
outil manquaient à l'appel alors en
fusionnant leurs compétences en
informatique et en biologie
les chercheurs ont créé
un logiciel navigateur de forme au
service de la biologie offrant la
possibilité d'étudier des objets
biologiques 3d à différentes échelles de
l'adn à l'anatomie et qui dit nouvel
outil de techniques d'imagerie dans le
domaine du vivant dix nouvelles
découvertes et d'ailleurs
connaissez-vous les ascidies quoi les
ascidies et rien à voir avec les jackson
five
mais qui les jackson five à toutes et
tous et il s'est dit hanane one two
three
une assise 10 est un animal marin
invertébrés et les scientifiques sont
taquins puisqu'ils l'ont nommée fah
l'usia même il atteint littéralement le
phallus avec des mamelles et c'est la
chouchoute des chercheurs car elle se
reproduit toute l'année la petite
coquine et elle possède l avantage
d'avoir des embryons très transparent et
donc idéaux à observer à tiens regarde
et revoilà ne dise embryons toutes les
deux minutes et pendant huit heures les
scientifiques ont enregistré les images
du développement de 10 embryons d'acide
grâce à un microscope à feuilles de
lumière avec l'ast est qu on passe de
ces images un modèle 3d que l'on peut
comparer à un genre de réalité virtuelle
et chaque petites briques de couleurs
que l'on voit ici représente une cellule
embryonnaire qui formera un même tissu
cerveau peau muscle et c'est avec
l'arrivée de morpho net on a pu explorer
ces modèles 3d sous toutes leurs
coutures les éclater les décortiquer
pour en comprendre les moindres
mécanisme en rentrant dans l'invisible
morpho net nous permet aussi d'observer
et suivre automatiquement chaque cellule
sa position ses contacts et ses
progénitures quand elle se divise en
gros ce logiciel nous transforme en
agent de la cia microscopiques
attendez on va faire une petite pause la
ve vous voyez cela mais regardez les
embryons se ressemblent comme deux
gouttes d'eau et ça au même moment comme
si les cellules étaient synchronisée et
collées entre elles
et ça c'est assez inhabituel pour des
embryons d'animaux dans les cellules
embryonnaires gigote d'habitude beaucoup
plus les scientifiques se sont rendu
compte que cette propriété était propre
à une poignée de groupes dont les
ascidies ici les cellules n'ont pas
besoin de crier pour s'agencer la
mécanique et différentes chacune tient
sa place se divisent et se spécialise en
restant proche de ses voisines
les chercheurs ont donc émis la
possibilité d'un mode de communication
non plus à longue distance mais beaucoup
plus discret pour résumer ici on se
chuchote les informations ces fleurons
tout est plus intime plus calme plus
soif on se laisse aller on touche ses
voisines et jeu pardon en plus de nous
apprendre toutes ces découvertes
aztèques et morpho net nous chuchote à
quel point il est important d'avoir de
nouveaux outils à partager dans la
recherche et comment la synergie entre
les domaines peut mener à de nouvelles
découvertes incroyables
morpho net c'est une nouvelle façon de
voir mais aussi de partager le vivant et
pas que sur des hassidim et plein
d'autres éléments
c'est également un navigateur en ligne
un peu comme une immense banque de
données biologiques 3d via laquelle on
peut recréer des événements biologique
par ordinateur et sans forcément avoir à
manipuler le vivant via des animaux par
exemple bref morpho net c'est morpho net
c'est la vie la stlévis tonnes pib alors
avoué ça valait le coup de rester
jusqu'au bout pour découvrir tout ça non
et puis en plus je suis certaine qu
après avoir visionné cet épisode vous
allez vous précipiter pour crier sur
tous les toits toutes ses connaissances
autour de vous ou alors peut-être
simplement les chuchoter dans tous les
cas à beaune toi sinon un but avec